You may have figured out we first need to convert 240 to the z score. In other
words we want to find out how many standard deviations away from the mean, 190,
240 is. So it's going to be one point something. So first we take the distance
between 190 and 240, and then we divide by the standard deviation, to find out
how many standard deviations fit into that distance. So we get about 1.39. We
have to round to the hundredths place, because the z table we have doesn't get
more precise than that. So our z score is 1.39, so let's bring up the table.
First, we find 1.3. And we find 0.09, which is the last column. And we find that
the area, less than a standard deviation of 1.39 is 0.9177. So this means that
approximately 91.77% of people will have less than 240 Facebook friends. And
remember, this is all assuming that this is a normal distribution with mean 190
and standard deviation 36.